Maxo fiance actually just posted that
new selfie so we had to find out what
Dancing's final four contestants think
about it but first how are they holding
up heading into next week's finale it's
been a very stressful week for him like
I'm obviously I'm stressed too but he
has to choreograph two dances it's the
finals
country singer Jana Kramer and partner
Gleb are feeling the pressure their
plans to reprise their most infamous
dance were next by the show for a
different kind of tango they won't let
us see the shower dance so what about
NFL star Calvin Johnson and Pro Lindsay
this week is honestly the most insane
week of the show I've been able to enjoy
most of it the nurse kind of went out
after the first week or two but now is
just about having a good time meanwhile
IndyCar driver James Hinchcliffe and
partner Sharna reveal what they will
miss most definitely the laughing and
the sense of humor the fact that I can
understand an entire sentence without
her saying a word I speak Sharna I'm I'm
leaving a very educated man Olympic
gymnast Lorie Hernandez in valve will
once again be joined by his big bro max
the people have spoken
wanna see max one last time who knows
maybe this is the last time I'm actually
dancing on the show so let's get it he's
36 years old watching from the sidelines
max fiance Peta Murgatroyd who just
posted this photo 33 weeks pregnant man
you know what's up dude oh yeah a woman
looks her best pregnant and even better
as a mother she's just the most
beautiful pregnant woman I love her so
much and I hate her at the same time
because her
you